on m'a donc coordonner d'organiser tous
les fêtes du mariage
sa majesté a décidé d'avancer des noces
de quelques mois il nous sommes
cruellement retard la mission est donné
il faut aider monsieur papillon de la
ferté intendant du roi louis 15 pour que
le mariage du futur louis saez et
marie-antoinette soit parfait de vrais
menus plaisirs
alors l'idée de ce rendez vous est venu
à nicolas bûcher directeur de centre de
musique baroque de versailles pour
répondre à la demande
dans ce contexte très particulier de
d'avoir des vacances
particulière à prenantes pour pour les
enfants
des yvelines on a souhaité mettre en
avant la diversité des arts de la scène
à l'époque enfin au disque du 17ème
18ème siècle et montrer en quoi toutes
ces disciplines
ce qu on se complétait avaient besoin
les unes des autres dans ce décor chant
mais aussi choix des costumes seyant à
travers divers ateliers et d'un
spectacle enfants et adultes se plonge
au coeur du xviiie siècle on a appris
beaucoup de choses donc au niveau des
costumes
voilà de ce que le roi mais tu es quand
il voulait partir à l'opéra qu'est ce
qui te plaît les ateliers
les amis qui font qu'ils sont bons avant
qu'on on a pu approfondir nos
connaissances sur ce qui se faisait
autour du château de versailles est donc
là avec les codes de la danse comme on
s'y prend c'est un ciel bas attaqueront
des choses anciennes la semaine est
réservée aux groupes sociaux et
éducatifs les familles seront accueillis
ce week end le public est attendu samedi
30 août à vous d'entrer dans la danse
ok